what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba here and it's John here so today
we're going to talk about an MMORPG game
that is tied into Wonder Woman actually
yeah and now if dot is or Godot however
you say obvious their last name she's
the official spokesperson in the game to
add just popped up on her official
Facebook and what's this game called
it's called legion of angels paradise
land non Mariners island paradise land
the whole limb now you may have heard of
legal angels paradise land because no no
there's been Wonder Woman herself gal
gadot is is officially endorsing this
video game so we actually saw Wonder
Woman at a late screening last night and
it was fantastic
yeah that's pretty blown away by yeah
and I was surprised by how many things
affected me in that I mean this guy was
speechless after it was done didn't even
want to talk about I guess UI gal gadot
will be willing to put her name in the
Wonder Woman image alongside this game
because of the fact that you know it has
similar elements to it you know it's a
mystical world you got a lot of strong
female characters in this game as well I
mean a lot of sword fighting and a lot
of crazy warrior skills a lot of small
costumes you know because when I watch
the movie I feel more like I'm the Steve
Trevor guy and you know it's the normal
American man the above average American
man who admires the strength of a
warrior woman you know because Wonder
Woman she is sexy she is beautiful the
beyond her model drop-dead gorgeous
looks she is also a skilled warrior and
she can she can she bows and arrows she
can we use a freaking lasso like no
one's business she can wield the sword
he wouldn't want I told her to be my
girlfriend when her moral compass is
true or a compass Matt dude north like
when I was watching her I was like I
want I want to date this woman I want a
girlfriend just like her I want to be
Steve Trevor and fall in love with a
woman who can protect me and you know
like a powerful woman today is a
wonderful and who puts me in my place
when I'm like oh you know we got to just
do something and then Wonder Woman I
loved about her but she was always that
what she's
woman who tells you like no we got to
stand up for what's right and a lot of
times in real life I'm like no I'm just
gonna do my thing this but if she does
it right I'm gonna have to have her back
yeah I'm gonna be the second in command
there she's standing speaks for what she
believes in and if you're in the way you
best look out yeah absolutely
while it has its fantastical elements in
it this the fantasy elements of a
hemisphere that we call yeah yeah and
you just spend a decent amount of time
on tennis gear getting to know you know
the amazon society and what life is like
for that how you know the Greek god Zeus
built this whole island for them to give
them a shield to protect them from the
outside world while it starts off in the
fantasy land it blends in perfect with
the real world as well all the film has
everything you want from a great comic
book movie from amazing action sequences
to Awesome humor it brings back an
element in its superhero films that you
haven't had in a while which is a true
sense of heroism
oh yeah and fighting for what's what's
right not just like I you know I got a
vendetta with this villain like there
there really does seem to be like a big
picture yeah movie spend a lot of time
dealing with that the whole idea of it's
not just black and white you can't just
kill one guy and have everybody be good
again yeah the essence of the world is
grey you know there's dark and light all
the time yeah part of what's so
beautiful about Wonder Woman is the fact
that they take a lot of time to revel in
that and to understand it yeah you know
like there really is a learning journey
for her to go absolutely because there's
the whole theme of the movie is hope
belief doing what's right it's not like
you get a scene late in the movie about
it it's it's a resonating themes
throughout the entire thing it's one of
those few superhero films that I've seen
where I'm truly inspired to be a better
person and become a woman
amazing it is like I want to be a woman
now I actually use any but it is one of
the superhero movies that
recent memories to me at least I thought
it sold a lot better than a lot of
superhero movies I've seen recently
actually just the idea that this is
about doing what's right yeah both need
help they always say that but some
movies I don't really feel you mean it
yeah feeling and and part of the wonder
of that movie is watching people try to
help yeah like I'm trying to do what I
think is right to help and they don't
always agree yeah and the movie takes
time to deal with that movie brought
tears to my eyes too and applause from
the crowd from her just making a stand
to do what's right it's one of those
films that's so neat because yes she has
superhero abilities but it really shows
it's about the gear inner character your
inner strength primarily above all else
be on external skills oh yeah and I mean
there's that whole there's that whole
vibe come out of like if you guys are
gonna help them just gonna do it myself
like I know what needs to happen so I'm
gonna fight yeah absolutely the main
strength of the film relies on gal gadot
performance throughout the entirety of
the picture and I got to be honest when
I first heard she was cast I was a
little doubtful because I haven't seen
any work of hers I was like can she
really carry an entire film well I can
she filled the shoes of such an icon
yeah
important character yeah and I boy does
she do it and actually Catic you earned
a number of big huge fan boy over here
after watching that movie on managers
Joe gird up and now okay yeah Gurdas did
a commercial for league of angels if she
did she lent her likeness is publicly
endorsing it though I want to watch it
really quick first we haven't seen good
gonna give you guys a 30-second reaction
here League of angels TV commercial
endorsed like I'll be done there she is
oh oh my gosh she's so good she's so
beautiful
yes she is pretty Kennedy got married at
23 does your ridiculous why'd you do
that so early you need more time to
explore why would you do that to me
oh wow
[Music]
right
[Applause]
but if you know just a second
bingo-bango what about you we're gonna
play a few minutes before I mean hell I
wasn't all out Cooper so yeah like a
full-on dragon attack that was crazy
they really committed to this whole
commercial man nothing little game
thrown and the characters here we heard
that a big reason why they were linking
Wonder Woman was to this character here
we did some research on it her name's a
Theresa I'm not mistaken right yeah from
from League of angels to living of
angels - and actually there are some
pretty big similarities between what I
could see why they featured the Teresa
character inside this commercial this
game is a huge world exploration as well
yeah I could specifically see why they
featured Teresa in here because Wonder
Woman herself she's a goddess she's a
princess she's drew a fatherless as well
and her mother has a rather traumatizing
background where she becomes a little
stubborn in her ways which is very
similar to actually how Wonder Woman's
mom is and also the fact that you know
because Teresa she's a princess as well
this was more dragons yeah - prejudice
also dragon princess yeah so that's a
bit different they both come from noble
birth they both come from like a father
a bit of a strong warrior woman at the
same time ruler drives and similar vigor
similar parenting and just in like
physical appearance - you know Wonder
Woman and Teresa they both have these
similar qualities of their exotic and
they there's a sweetness and an
innocence to them but in their eyes
there's also a boldness and a little bit
of coldness inside of them because they
have to have this level of certain
strength their arms from whatever nation
termination exactly exactly so they I
could see that similar features there
alone and in terms of skill set you know
a bottom line Wonder Woman and Teresa
the similar quality to them as it became
known as like the ultimate warrior woman
they both got the god gene they got the
god gene then they got the god genes and
then what they use them to fight for the
betterment of the world you know so
despite because a lot of times in this
god mythological world they can be a
little self
a little selfish yeah but here they use
it for to protect and fight for everyone
and that's a similar quality in terms of
skills that because while they both have
God powers bestowed upon them they kind
of just look like human form and they're
able to do superhuman abilities
throughout as well so like their
background is similar their skill set is
similar and even there's even similar
physical appearances as well and in
other similar quality is a league of
angels as a team of heroes and similar
to Wonder Woman Wonder Woman was a solo
hero who eventually joined the Justice
League becomes part of the team of
heroes and that's similar Teresa she is
this daughter of granddaughter of
Ulysses yeah yeah I don't know if it's V
Ulysses but it's certainly a reference
yeah to Greek yeah so she she has God
blood in her she's a solo warrior first
of course she eventually joined the team
of League of angels well yeah and she
was raised by her mother she's kind of
alienated from the crowd because of her
you know distinct bloodline act kind of
like Diana Princess of the mascara she's
different from everybody man and she's
uh she's rebellious but the funny thing
is is that even though they use Theresa
in this commercial for the character in
league of angels that is completely
mirrored after a gal gadot actual
physical appearance and a legend angel
on the icon it pops up a couple of times
so she is play the energy but if you
want to jump in together yeah shoes
godot's shoe how are you saving it you
want to jump into her shoes and do
battle in a fantasy realm you can do
that yeah you can't place her there's a
reason why God lends her face and her
natural image to this game as well right
and now I just want to play the game
yeah let's do it's all about here's the
plot I found it the story of paradise
land takes place in the world with
Elysium where a nefarious power has
toppled the rule of the Angels the
strife between the humans elves and orcs
have intensified even more when the
prophecy of the apocalypse spread across
the land it became woven into the fabric
of fate
legend says only the Omega an ancient
relic of the Angels has the power to
alter the grim fate of the world and
prevent
n-woo so while Wonder Woman has the
godlike elements it also has a lot of
elements of other you know fantasy stuff
that we've seen before or the Rings
cuckoos Nordea my trillions Game of
Thrones
alright so here we are whoa oh this
looks like this this whole the whole
background everything looks like that
this gear this does look like where the
Amazonians come from worth with dialogue
hello pretending you don't remember
anything classic I find you two days ago
lay it out next to the docks being the
kind of hired person that I am I've
brought you your boss you're back the
kids awake listen up buttercup we're
short-handed I'm not going to ask you
with too many questions it's not my
business my hast forgotten we got to
read this a lot quicker not a move hurry
to the village alright
challenge okay there's the sign alright
here we go a few days back monsters
attacks on our fortune took all the
length up the first time either we don't
deal with them now the foragers will go
on strike oh okay here we go
let me Jon Snow saying I'll join you
because you helped me out but only if
you admit this is where veges pure and
simple by the way you could cover snow
totally happy Jon Snow I'm little which
the boss here is called Templar was a
huge variety of characters it's like
Game of Thrones meets Wonder Woman got
its aspects 200 okay here we jumping
into the battle I see blue I get a I get
a wolf guy there's actually some pretty
cool graphics in here I wouldn't
oppresses me when athene was actually
happy it's really awesome graphic yeah I
like this sort of drawn you know art
look of the background wow that was the
easiest battle I've ever fought in my
entire life right there we already
upgraded to level 2 easiest thing in the
world challenge moving right along so
this game is good it makes me feel like
I'm getting stuff done deepest parts of
a wall lie ahead but it's already
getting hard those new quickly this
poisonous fog is too much cop cop I
can't breathe
did he say that out loud urgh potion of
poison resistance and the Wizards guilt
provides immunity for a while anyway
and actually it tastes pretty good add
some bubbles and tell it to kids you'll
make a fortune
how interesting okay who's that up ahead
I think it's more people problems we got
a kick 1 hour later they're away up
ahead or now we're better our run out
whoa well
fight back do some power I need a gap
but I got a load up my attacks first
I'll do the cool attack all right all
right six dudes out one Wow we just need
to wait some more oh did you see that
there's a boat in the river over there
our luck again say I like these app
games when you can easily just hit a few
buttons and do some cool move it's not
some complicated PC yeah this surveys
complicated just in typical Conville
game turn-based mmo's are easy to get it
yeah they're heavy are awesome graphic
designs but easy to play so that way you
can just move swiftly along yes yeah I
kind of just want to chill out and like
drink in the background yeah the world
the levels go by pretty quick here yeah
like whoa we're back in a battle this
kind of reminds me of like Final Fantasy
a little bit too yeah yeah Majesty lost
your memories if this is awful
thank goodness you survived I got that
guy's got it's hard to write play I
could actually see why gal gadot was
willing to endorse this the island set
up and the whole theme of being a team
of warriors because it's one thing one a
woman has to it's a team of warriors not
only with the Amazonian woman but also
even in the real world where it's
warriors from the inner strength so it's
like that's why you get this ride new
characters in this game as well well
they're traveling too like it's the
thing about Wonder Woman like the group
is like traveling you know battling
along their way to their to their goal
yeah dangerous however it's a good thing
I'm Way smarter than me again
- pull themselves see I think I think
right now what's happening we're in the
early levels where it's a million times
easier look at that they have an
elevator if she eventually is going to
pilot elevator and start making my own
decisions and you know that's going to
be so it's like building up your powers
right now I'm go ahead points and
everything that way you can start making
more of your own choices
yeah and one and I played a little bit
of this yesterday and leveled up quite a
bit and you echoed you actually get to
expand your team and you can change the
formation of your team you know so you
can have them attack from defense Sharda
that's like Jabba's it looks like I have
a shot yeah oh we're doing it
whoa oh it is it's that girl from the oh
it's my new girlfriend I mean just the
new it is you I have like awesome run
I am kneazle to the moon and again I
take it you haven't seen an angel before
angels are rarely encountered in these
times I was still under the impression
that only ghosts lie about how kids can
play this game so where's the kid can
he'd better not go in looking for
treasure on his own
I got a problem it's not a pendant with
it it seems to have a mark of winter
veil upon it it is a relic of this
pendant it seems familiar I seem to have
encouraged to put it on I like this guy
tells us how he's feeling what I'm so
dizzy
of course can I be about to die again no
use your direwolf johns now I gotta say
you know whenever I play an app that is
based on a video game already on console
I'm like a little bit egotistical and
expect the graphics be amazing but
whenever it's just an original game for
an app alone it surprises me when the
graphics are actually it is good yeah
yeah I don't know much about designing
apps but you know I think there's a lot
of worship he has affection of detail
and all the hand drawings and I got to
imagine it it's slightly different you
know when you're when you're designing
something that has a more tanned drawn
look in your
you know your backgrounds your some
side-scrolling in a way yeah you're not
worried about like so much 3d cuz that's
gotta pay it's very time-consuming oh
there she is there she is that's the
Wonder Woman we were talking about man
eventually we got to build up to get her
though we got to build it up all right
where are we going next we've taken
another adventure I'm pretty sure
there's a way where you can set it up
where you can actually play other users
online and burst them yeah you can and
some of that last night I was a lot of
people I want to battle you beat another
player yeah I do that with my solitaire
app and now I'm on level 12 that's true
whoa oh it's getting harder now yeah see
now I actually have to think about what
I'm doing paintin still with you with
these different tricks doing all that so
this guy I like the designs of these
characters on you know some of them are
a bit familiar but I think they're all
cool fantasy you can download this game
on your iPhone or your Android for free
at your App Store go check it out there
gal gadot playing it I'm gonna play a
tip it in a simple away I work because
you know why there's one of women's on
you leader love all DC characters
especially right now wonderfully leading
the pack right now well by a wide bernie
is the best one is the best one have a
DC EU currently I hope she's the leader
of the Justice League if that man I
don't [ __ ] wonder who I trust you the
most out of all these characters right
now you seem like oh it is actually
truthfully concerns the right man I just
want to play it up to the game to get to
the point where I could download her
character the one that looks like her so
I can be gal gadot I would like to tell
you if I had a chance to be not even
Wonder Woman yoga I just want to be the
actress yeah I would be happy about that
and have my character returned in the
Fast & Furious franchise alright well
that's it for today's video guys you can
subscribe to the real reject that's on
Humphrey Twitter and Instagram download
League of angels paradise land have a
good day and go see Wonder Woman in
theaters now